>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Our final speaker before break is
Geoff Haines-Stiles, who has worked
on Innovative Science
Media Project since 1978
when he was series
director and senior producer
for Carl Sagan's landmark, an
Emmy-winning COSMOS series.
He's here today to talk
about The Crowd & The Cloud
and how citizen science has
revolutionized scientific data.
Science by, for and with the
people, how citizen, science
and mobile tech have revolutionized
the collection, sharing
and use of scientific data.
Geoff, take it away.
>> Geoff Haines-Stiles:
I was going to say,
and now for something
completely different,
but every single talk has been
completely different, so I won't say
and now for something
completely different.
But thanks to the Library
of Congress
for inviting us all along today.
And I've got some references
from what we saw yesterday
that actually tie into some
of the themes of this talk.
I've been a science
producer since 1980.
It's taken me to the ends of
the Earth, which is fortunate,
because in the Antarctic,
they give you helmets
to cover your bald spot,
so everything is good.
I'm here today to talk
about The Crowd & The Cloud.
My collaborators on that
project are Waleed Abdalati,
a former NASA Chief Scientist.
You'll see him in a
video clip in a moment.
And my collaborator in life
and work, Erna Akuginow,
who's in the front there.
Thank you, Erna.
Recent grandmother.
Congratulations.
And see, the Library of Congress
congratulates you as well.
Isn't this great?
So as was said, I've had a
great time working with some
of the most celebrated
scientists in the country,
and also comedians like Lily Tomlin.
What I hadn't been aware of until
I was walking around yesterday is
that the Library of Congress
actually has a great collection
of Alan Lomax memorabilia.
I've worked with him on a
series called American Patchwork
about roots music.
The Crowd & The Cloud, funded by
the National Science Foundation,
is designed to increase
the visibility, credibility
and participation in
citizen science.
Now, how many people in the audience
could define citizen science
at a cocktail party?
That's about five or six
people out of a couple hundred.
So that's one of the
reasons that we decided
that we should try
and do this series.
Citizen science is
definitely a coming trend.
You'll hear from some of the
citizen scientists yourselves.
These are some of the
words that have been used
to define citizen science
over the past few years.
You'll see cyber is
in a lot of them.
A lot of them have natural
history environments
as part of the subject matter.
One of my favorite ones
is nerds for nature,
and there's actually a citizen
science project called nerds
for nature.
Another way of saying that,
however, would be science for, by,
for and with the people
that you may notice comes
from the Gettysburg Address, and
again, Lincoln is a great presence
in the Library of Congress.
I was pleased to find
that out yesterday.
We've created four one-hour
programs that debuted
on public television
this last spring.
I'm going to show you a large number
of video clips, which accounts
for me trying to talk rather fast.
Crowdandcloud.org is where you can
find all of the programs streaming
in realtime if what we
show you is of interest.
Our premise is to try and
turn viewers into doers.
Not just to have a good
time watching a TV show,
but actually to be
encouraged to become part
of the citizen science movement.
And it wouldn't be possible
without collaboration with a number
of government agencies and NGOs
and citizen science projects.
So this is how we begin the series,
and this is how we
begin this presentation.
>> The Crowd & The Cloud
is made possible by NSF,
the National Science Foundation,
where discoveries begin.
[ Music ]
>> This is today's citizen science.
People pursuing their
passions, and at the same time,
generating data that's
useful for research.
>> I love surfing.
I love science.
And I get to go surfing for science.
>> Technology is a way to
really get people outside
and to look more carefully
at the natural world.
>> There are now more mobile phones
on Earth than people on our planet.
And new technologies can
help solve major challenges.
>> Every single data
point has a human story.
>> Now communities can use
science to tackle local problems.
>> The state doesn't come and
say, you've got to clean this up.
So we started on the bucket brigade.
>> They're linking sensors and
citizens to find solutions.
>> I'm learning about toxins.
I'm learning how to teach
other people to do what I do
so they can do it for themselves.
>> It was a lonely disease.
But propellor sensors are going to
revolutionize the asthma treatment.
>> Collaborating via the
cloud, the crowd can save time,
save money and save lives.
We're surely smarter together.
I'm Waleed Abdalati, host
of The Crowd & The Cloud.
I've studied Earth's ice sheets
from satellites and aircraft.
And I was NASA Chief
Scientist at the time
when curiosity landed on Mars.
So I know big data and big science.
But I'm also convinced
that citizen-generated
data has an important role.
No longer is science something
only done by professionals in labs.
No more is data just the property
of corporations in government.
>> For years, you've watched
science on public television.
Now you're invited to do science.
>> Geoff Haines-Stiles: Well, I hope
you can see we've got a wide variety
of projects that we feature
in the series, a wide variety
of folks who are involved.
Citizen science actually
has a long history.
The background here is Thomas
Jefferson's weather records dating
back to the 1770s.
And today's citizen
science is looking
at whether 20,000 observers are
recording daily precipitation
measurements, including
one, at least it was there,
on the left-hand side, a rain gauge
in Michelle Obama's
vegetable garden.
So these are contributing data that
the National Weather Service uses
to update flash flood warnings.
History of the Christmas
Bird Count goes back to 1900.
It's one of the longest
running citizen science projects
in the United States.
But contemporary citizen science
also includes the make of movements,
millennials, folks like the people
that are part of public lab.
And this is a gratuitous shot
just because it makes me think
of arcade fire on tour, but these
are actually citizen scientists
flying balloons underneath kites
to document the BP oil spill
off of Deepwater Horizon.
Contemporary citizen science
also includes putting sensors,
microscopic sensors on surfboard
fins to look at ocean acidification
and sea surface temperature.
So as we said, a great variety.
Trying to tie my presentation to
the themes of this conference,
I'm going to talk about
three different kinds
of data collection and sharing.
In some cases, it's a question of
data that's putting communities
on the map and helping
to solve problems.
And that's what this next
little clip is about.
The West Oakland Environmental
Indicator's Project, it was founded
to try to look at truck routes
going through West Oakland
and how truck routes were
corresponding to asthma attacks
in senior citizen centers
and daycare centers.
They managed to get the truck
routes that you saw in red replaced
by the truck routes in green by
going out and counting trucks.
Not counting birds, counting trucks,
and then going to city government
to get them to move
the truck routes away
from the most heavily
populated areas.
They've continued their
work reaching out to kids,
trying to get kids excited about
the new generation of sensors.
And this next little clip
shows how excited the teams,
like in the project that
Tom and Patrick showed you,
get when they're doing
authentic research.
In this case, it's not an archive.
They're using their environment,
their community as
the source of data.
>> When the students have
been able to go out and walk
around the community and collect
data and then observe things,
they understand the correlation
between the data and the sources
of pollution that they're
interested in.
>> This is called the dust tracker.
It measures how much dust
and particular matter
there is in the air.
Particular matter is the little
dust particles that we can't see.
The more cars pass by, the more
particular matter there is.
And the less cars that pass
by, the less there are.
>> So the air filter in
there, there's a cartridge.
They can send that out
and test particulars.
And they found that
it's kinds of metals.
And most of those things
are from the brakes,
from the wheels and from the tracks.
So if you think about
metal, you're breathing it.
If it's a metal.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Because of the low cost sensors
available and the smart phones
or their devices, the
students can collect data
and immediately begin
interpreting them.
>> In December, 2015, some of the
students presented their findings
at the American Geophysical
Union, which is one of the largest
and busiest gatherings
of professional earth
and space scientists.
>> We come to AGU,
like that's amazing.
Like I didn't really realize
how big of a deal it was
until I started looking into it,
and we have something to bring
to the table, just us
high school students.
And people want to hear
what we have to say.
And it's kind of exciting, like
what I'm doing like really matters.
>> It does matter.
It does matter.
>> Yeah, it gives us hope,
like we might change something,
you know, like a taste of art.
>> We sometimes frighten
the statisticians
because they would prefer to have
a little bit of perfectly pristine,
absolutely, you know, 100% data
from a million dollar machine.
And we're saying, no, no, let's take
this, you know, 200 dollar machine
and start making decisions
based on it.
But the notion is that
if you had, you know,
a 1 million dollar machine,
you can do so much with that.
But if you have a million hundred
dollar machines, all spewing data
into the cloud, turning it back
to us in a direct feedback loop,
then we start to adjust
behavior immediately.
>> Geoff Haines-Stiles: So the
second category is citizen science.
I'm going to talk about where
there is no data, where there seems
to be no agencies that are
involved in gathering the data
as you might expect
and sharing that.
This is an example from
the second program,
which is called Citizens
Plus Scientists,
of where a concerned citizen,
Deb, you'll see her in the piece.
But because it's an edited segment,
it doesn't have the name supers.
That's why the names are
here at the beginning.
Was concerned about air
pollution in her area,
resulting from oil
and gas development.
She went to an NGO, Denny Larson's
Bucket Brigade, captured data.
And you'll see a little bit
about how data is captured.
And then shared that through
the peer review process
with a big result in
terms of state policy.
So it goes all the way from
data collection to social good,
socially beneficial results.
>> It took right out a
hundred double semi-loads
to get the rig out.
It was a triple rig.
You know, the traffic
went from maybe 3
or 4 cars a week to like 50 a day.
Tons of dust on this county road.
They'd flare for months.
They'd light the flare, and the
whole crick bottom would shake.
And so our house would just shake.
Lots of noise.
All the wildlife just took off.
There was spills and leaks.
And nobody cleans it up.
Nobody says anything
or does anything.
There's no oversight.
The state doesn't come out and
say, you've got to clean this up.
It's left to the people
who are living there.
>> The first thing that happens
is the sites are selected.
The citizen scientists are
trained on-site by ourselves.
They've got a set number of
samples that they can take.
So the samples are taken, literally
taking, you know, a plastic bucket
and putting some stainless steel on
it that will hold the sample bag.
It's like a loan.
So the bucket is the body, the bag
is the loan, and then there's a pump
which serves as your diaphragm,
which pumps the air out,
creating negative pressure,
opening the bag and bringing in air
so it can be sealed and
sent to the lab for testing.
And they process it immediately.
>> Bucket brigade techniques
have been reviewed by the EPA
and have been found to be
useful in capturing data
where government sensors
are lacking.
>> I was shocked.
I didn't think we'd find much.
And we found emissions
off the freaking charts.
>> We found that many of the
samples exceeded those standards.
Some for benzene were something like
10,000 times above the standard.
>> Many of the toxic chemicals
that are known to cause cancer
that we found in this report
were, in some cases, hundreds.
In other cases, thousands.
And in one case, 22 million
times over the EPA cancer risk.
>> These are enormous releases.
Many of these components
are neurotoxins.
At high concentrations, they
can actually cause coma.
But at later concentrations, they
tend to reduce brain function.
The long-term effects,
the biggest one is cancer.
Because several of these
are known human carcinogens.
>> So when we started doing
the Bucket Brigade, this five,
six state Bucket Brigade,
we didn't intend
on doing the peer-reviewed article.
We were just going to do the report.
>> I became involved in the
fracking study when the groups
that had coordinated the
community-based activities
approached me for assistance
doing the statistical analysis
of the data, writing
up the publication,
and getting it published
in a peer-reviewed journal.
And whenever there is
this kind of study,
having a peer-reviewed
publication is sort
of the good housekeeping seal
of legitimacy of a study.
>> What happens with citizen
science is everybody disses it.
So the peer-reviewed article
was extremely important
because it gave validity
to citizen science.
>> I think that's why we
got taken so seriously,
that our journal article
had been published,
and this is what academic
scientists and doctors were saying
about the extreme hazard
from oil and gas development.
And there was widespread
coverage across the U.S.
and actually globally of both the
peer-reviewed study and the report.
And it had a major impact.
>> I think the greatest influence
from the warning signs report
was for the ban in New York.
>> Our fracking study was waved
by the commissioner of health
when he made the announcement
that the governor
of New York was banning fracking.
>> Geoff Haines-Stiles: So the last
genre of citizen science I'm going
to talk about is really
more like crowd sourcing.
And this is where there's so much
data, rather than the lack of data
in the case of fracking
or the public lab work,
the Deepwater Horizon.
There is so much data
coming out of research lab
that you can crowd source it much
faster than the work could be done
by researchers themselves.
So this story is about the folks up
at Cornell who are looking to see
if they can figure out
the causes of Alzheimer's.
And they think it's reduced
blood flow in the brain.
They experiment on mice.
They take videos of mouse brains.
And they then have the problem
that it takes them a week
to capture the data, but
a year to analyze it.
So they've turned to the crowd.
They've borrowed from
or adapted examples
from successful gamified
citizen science projects,
including the NASA Stardust Mission,
where 30,000 people playing a game
were essentially able to find traces
of interstellar particles,
and EyeWire,
which is looking at
neurons in the brain.
Putting this together, they
were able to borrow from all
of the lessons of web games in
terms of having leader boards,
competition, fighting to
have your name up there
on the top of the leader board.
And this is how a citizen
science project was demoed
in a retirement community in Florida
playing the store catcher's game.
You can see the excitement
that these senior citizens got
from trying to help speed
up Alzheimer's research.
[ Music ]
>> In late 2016, EyesOnALZ released
its Stall Catchers game based
on the Stardust Interface.
The public was invited to
help crowd source the analysis
of blocked blood vessels.
Some of the first players
were in Central Florida.
They were retirees who had
chosen the warm climate
in a community with plenty to do.
>> How many of you have family,
friends, somebody close to you
that either has or did have
Alzheimer's, or you have it?
Just about everybody, huh?
If only the scientists work on it,
it might take as much as 30 years.
And for most of us, that's
not going be a big benefit.
This is what the game looks like.
And you can get it on your
phone, your tablet, your laptop.
>> Does the game change every day?
>> Yes, yes, they keep going.
They keep putting you through.
>> What do you think?
>> Oh, yeah, yeah.
>> How many think that it's flowing?
How many think it's stalled?
Shall we find out?
>> Yes.
>> Well, try Stall then, okay?
I've got 402 points.
Thank you very much.
There we go.
We're climbing.
Every time we find a stalled one
that is really stalled,
we are helping big time.
>> One of the things that I
like about this research is
that we can help my mother's
generation, but I'm 64.
And, you know, while
I want to help my mom,
this is going to help,
I call kids, my age.
>> EyesOnALZ will keep on
refining its game play interface.
But its greatest impact on
Alzheimer's research will come
from the limitless
power of the crowd.
>> Geoff Haines-Stiles: So
one of the common questions
about citizen science is the
data quality reliable enough?
And the folks behind the
EyesOnALZ project worked on that,
and they have been able
to find that relative
to laboratory grade research,
the crowd is doing very well.
Originally, they thought they
would have to have 20 members
of the crowd to validate
each result.
They've now gone down to 7 to
8 people, looking at each piece
of data to get quality results.
So data quality is often
raised about citizen science.
The quality of many citizen science
projects has been demonstrated
in statistics that I think any
of you would find convincing.
While our series was on the
air back in April and May
and PBS stations will be rerunning
it on into the next couple of years,
but just last weekend, we
did a global catch-a-thon,
modeled on the sort of
open street map map-a-thons
in which you give people
pizza, have them get together
to do a mapping of streets.
This time, EyesOnALZ
coordinated a global effort,
22 teams in 6 different continents
on 6 different continents playing
a game within an hour to see
who could actually code the
largest number of stalls.
And you can see some
of the people there.
Guatemala, El Salvador,
Chile, China, Brazil,
all around the world people
were online playing this game
when we did a live zoom
hangout to document that.
The winners were actually
done in Chile.
You can see that they annotated
1,955 examples of brain science,
and then they celebrated and
everybody got to share in that.
Citizen science has, in fact,
become a global phenomenon
with citizen science
associations in Australia,
and also in Europe
being very strong.
Some of the apps developed in Spain
are actually now being used here
in the United States as well.
This is called mosquito alert
with the concern about Zika.
Anything that citizens
can do to report the areas
in which there is a breeding site
for mosquitoes is very important.
This little video just shows
you that these are the sites
of traditional locations
of live traps.
But they're fairly limited.
This is the number of
citizen science reports
that came in in Spain.
So my time is up.
Coffee break is looming.
I'm going to just zip over the
next few things just to say
that there is an NSF project
using $6 microscopes to attach
to the smart phones
that are also part
of today's citizen
science revolution.
And I'm skipping over that
and ending here by saying
that it's a revolution that is
happening, it's powered by people,
it is really answering concerns
that communities and citizens have.
But it's using the tools of
science, it's generating data
from the environment, analyzing
it, collaborating with scientists,
and then delivering back
solutions that work.
So citizens plus sensors
working for solutions,
that's a pretty good summary of
what today's citizen science is.
And Erna and I will be happy to talk
to anybody over the break about any
of the things we've just said.
So thanks very much Library of
Congress for putting this on.
Delighted to be here.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.